you get the feeling that there's always
a party going on at Google the company
is constantly celebrating one product
launch after the next be it music
platforms or self-driving cars
cutting-edge technology all pretty far
from what Google started out as a simple
search engine the search engine part
still applies today it's just not that
simple anymore critics accused the
internet giant of invasive practices
arguing that it saves and analyzes way
too much user data Europeans are
concerned an alliance of four hundred
european firms and institutions have
lodged an anti competition complaint
with the european commission taking a
look back the company was founded in
1998 and went public a decade ago the
offering price back then eighty five
dollars a share this year Google stocks
broke through the six hundred dollar
mark so does Google wield too much money
and power on the internet that's the
issue in the EU and especially in
Germany economy minister Sigmar Gabriel
would like to see the company broken up
a scenario not possible under current
law